[Music]
hi everyone I would like to welcome you
to at the table my name is Don Jacobs
and I'm wearing the birth of the table
and I'm so glad that you were with us
today it has been still very crazy we're
still doing this from home but we're
thankful we can do this in this way and
still connect to you and reach as many
people as we possibly can through this
method I just have one quick
announcement about the e3 conference
that's coming up in October you can it's
being hosted by centerpiece this is
something that I also I've experienced
when I attended the last time it was in
Dallas it was something that I when I
when I didn't know exactly what I was
walking into I thought I was gonna walk
in and see if I'm sure other LGBT
Christians and get here all this other
stuff and meet lots of people from all
over the place it was surprising that I
saw a lot of people that was that were
they're just learned they were they were
not literally LGBT there were a lot of
parents there was a lot of pastors youth
ministers um there were just people that
were like they had a friend or family
member that was a career person and we
just wanted to learn more about what was
going on and these were people that came
across the whole entire United States so
they lived from all over all over the
country so I told certainly encourage
you to maybe sign up for them it's
October the 22nd 23 this ring for you
can go to centerpiece net and they have
that information for you
to get registered and the earlybird rate
is really good as good all the way until
the 1st of July so it's coming up very
quickly so to kind of get us started I
want us to lead us into your prayer Lord
I just want to thank you so much for
this opportunity to just to for table
family members to get together to gather
around to focus on you and what you have
for us for today Laurie I pray that you
just be with us open up our hearts and
our minds to are just to you and
connecting with you and pray that you
will just we'll just help us to be able
to understand what you have is we need
the fact here from you today aboard in
Christ and we pray amen I believe that
you have my fortress you have my portion
you have my hiding place I believe you
are the true
life I believe you are the way the truth
the life I believe in to ever be
blessing to ever be promise to every
breath I take I believe that you are
provider oh yes you are
[Music]
Senora I'm stood on you and you leave
here today mercy said a new on the fears
and doubts think it all come to because
take kids day long but I'm here with you
some new Verizon I'm set on you can you
read me here today
let's see set a new on my fears and
doubts they get all come to because they
can't stay I believe
[Music]
[Applause]
because the truth the life I believe you
are oh yes you are
[Music]
Oh God
thanks Kerry I'm so glad you guys are
all with us and I really love the bridge
of that song I always just feel like I
can connect with those lyrics and I feel
like they're pretty fitting right now as
we are all in a new horizon whether we
want it to be or not there is so much
happening from week to week in our world
right now in our nation that it just
feels like there's constantly
adjustments to be made and that we're
not necessarily we don't have much
control over what going on so I hope
that shipping night together that we can
really embrace just the faith and trust
that God is holding us together and the
key is walking this journey with us in
all of its highs and lows that not far
away it is close and that hopefully at
the end it's good for me to remember
that he is somehow like outside of my
timeframe and my timetable and at the
end of this I hope that we're able to
look back on this season and see his
goodness woven in out of it so I asked
Maggie if she would do this song
goodness I thought again and yeah I just
I just asked God that you would hold us
all to sink
you are somewhere in your sustaining us
we grieve and rejoicing with us when we
rejoice that you are
[Music]
and we just want to hang on to the buzz
as a family has a community guide and
help us to carry that with us into every
situation into every relationship and
conversation and the adjustments all the
unknowns God
[Music]
never fails in your hands
face
[Music]
I
my life you have
[Music]
I
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
help us to be a piece inside
be our constant be our Center we are
pieces
and no matter what the situation we find
ourselves
[Music]
[Applause]
well
good evening everyone this is quite
visits transition so whenever we make
the series intro videos you don't always
know the vibe coming out of the previous
but it's great to be with you all and
grace and peace happy to be with all of
you through technology and I loved
[Music]
[Applause]
all right with any luck that is better
though I can make no guarantees let me
look at my live comments how how are you
experiencing my voice right now live
comments it's a little better okay we'll
just proceed all right cool
thanks max for letting me know um all
right so let's see I wanted to oh I want
to mention so this is the last week of
Pride Month so I wanted to say yes of
course welcome to all of you but to our
gay lesbian bisexual transgender friends
who call the table home or if you're
just you know online connect with us a
just a special and very warm welcome to
you you are I wouldn't just name really
clearly you are the beloved of God and
we are so privileged to have you as part
of our community it means a lot to us
we're richer for your presence so thank
you for being here and the rest of you
you're all we're so glad you're here too
but you know special call-out so um this
is now I think week two in our series on
the Gospel of Luke and as we discussed
last week the Book of Luke it's it's
really um neither like a pure just
history of Jesus at least in the the
kind of modern historical sense nor is
it a a biography of Jesus in a sense of
chronicling his like inner world and you
know as he journeyed through his public
ministry instead we what we named last
week is that it's it was it's kind of
more like a documentary film though of
course Britain now Luke though not
himself a disciple or an eyewitness to
the life of Christ
um he did have access to people who had
been eyewitnesses
Jesus himself and so Luke proceeds kind
of as the director of his literary
documentary to weave together the
testimonies and accounts into a
narrative structure so that's what we're
encountering when we come to the Gospel
of Luke that that's that's what we're
experiencing so last week we looked at
the passage from Luke 1 about the the
story of the birth of John the Baptist
tonight is gonna be a little bit
different it's going to be where in Luke
chapter 3 and this is now kind of John's
all grown up
so the title of the message tonight is
start here start here and like I
mentioned will be in Luke 3 so let's see
so that kind of complete context so John
ut's grown up he's now a prophet his
public ministry and in many ways was
preparing the people to to hear and to
receive Jesus message so that's why Luke
is including him giving him you know so
much space in these early chapters so
you would be kinda the preparer of the
way so to speak so our text tonight is
not about the early public ministry of
Jesus but instead it is about John so
let's go ahead and read our text so
we're gonna start in Luke chapter 3
verses 1 through 10 it says in the
fifteenth year of the reign of Tiberius
Caesar when Pontius Pilate was governor
of Judea Herod Tetrarch of Galilee his
brother Philip Tetrarch of I Turia and
Shrek and itís in licenese tetrarch of
abilene during the high priesthood of
Anna's and Caiaphas the Word of God came
to John son of Zechariah in the
wilderness he went into all of the
country around the Jordan preaching a
baptism of repentance for the
forgiveness of sins as is written in the
book of the words of Isaiah the prophet
a voice of one calling in the wilderness
prepare the way for the Lord make
straight paths for him every Valley
shall be filled and every mountain and
Hill made low the crooked roads shall
become straight the rough ways smooth
and all people will see God's salvation
so you can
they're kind of a description of John's
ministry he's preparing the way for the
Lord right Jesus is gonna follow John's
to prepare so he's the like if you think
of a band he's like the warm-up act for
the big band you know he's like he's
pretty then good and of himself but he's
you know he's getting people prepared so
now verse 7 John said to the crowds
coming out to be baptized by him he's a
real charmer as you'll see you brood of
vipers who warned you to flee from the
coming wrath produce fruit in keeping
with repentance do not begin to say to
yourselves we have Abraham as our Father
he's referencing there you know all the
way back to the book of Genesis father
Abraham you know as Abraham Isaac Jacob
the kind of patriarch of the faith so we
have Abraham as our Father for I tell
you out of these stones God can raise up
children for Abraham the axe is already
at the root of the trees and every tree
that does not produce good fruit will be
cut down and thrown into the fire
verse 10 what should we do then the
crowd asked alright now it's possible
that the crowd is like just trying to
save their own skin I mean they could be
saying I'm not sure how a metaphorical
that last line was but if there's any
way I could avoid the whole cut down and
thrown into the fire portion of our
evening that would be wonderful so just
tell me what what should I do but that's
a little cynical let's go with the idea
that they're listening to a powerful
preacher there I mean they're really
genuinely moved on like they really do
care they really do want to change let's
assume that they're what should we do
then is really really genuine it's that
so then I think we can hear in their
question kind of a universal question a
question that that that's relevant to
all of us that we might find ourselves
asking in different ways too
people at different times even outside
of like a purely religious context I
mean I'm thinking for example of the the
girlfriend or the boyfriend who has
offended or wounded their significant
other and they're trying to have a
conversation about it and it's going
very poorly and finally the girlfriend
just yells like well what do you want me
to do I don't even know what you want me
to do what what do you what do you want
me to change who do you want me to
become or I'm imagining those times in
our lives when maybe just in life in
general things are going poorly and we
shake our fists at the heavens and do we
say something similar what what what do
you want from me what what do you want
me to do and that's I think a statement
that is multiplied with slightly
different language in 10,000 different
ways all over our world every day well
what should we do then and of course in
our own moment of koban 19 mental health
crises racial equality political
polarization I mean all those things
that's just United States I'm not even
talking about there's other problems
that span the globe oh and murder
Hornets don't forget about the murder
ones those were 20 20 as well we got to
toss those then we got issues right so
so I think it in many ways
many of us are right there with John's
audience kind of throwing up our hands
saying what what what should we do what
can we do and here's what's interesting
John gives an incredibly surprising
response and it's surprising at least to
me because it it doesn't have anything
to do with our usual go-to responses in
other words um you know it has nothing
to do with I'll just list a few um
outward forms of religious observance
you know I'm thinking prayers church
attendance scripture reading you know he
they don't say what should we do then
and he says well you need to be a church
this Sunday or they're Jewish so
Saturday you know that he doesn't say or
well you've barely
memorize the scriptures like it's not
where he goes another thing he doesn't
talk he doesn't point them towards we
might call it inward feelings of piety
yeah that's kind of the the inner life
kind of cultivating this inner you know
love for God and feelings of reverence
and a sense of holiness you know he
doesn't say yeah think think thoughts
about God or something he doesn't that's
not really what he says he also here's
what's interesting he also doesn't give
a critique of the systems in our world
that in fact do like perpetuate
inequality and injustice and things and
it was plain in his day he could have
pointed out yes he doesn't go that road
um but he also doesn't mention
inspirational messages he doesn't give
them these inspirational messages like
you know they're like what should we do
and he's like you've got to become world
changers guys nope he doesn't tell them
they can change the world nothing like
that
now am I saying points a B C and D above
that these like don't matter of course
not in fact both Jesus and even John
himself in other places touch on like
all of those things in different ways
but when John says repent and start
producing good fruit in your life and
this is a common metaphor he and later
Jesus would use the idea of a good tree
producing good fruit
aka a good person producing good fruits
of the Spirit in their life right so
when when John says to repent and start
producing good fruit in your life and
the people ask how do we do that like
what does that look like what what then
should we do what strikes me about his
response is that it's it's so so simple
and so concrete verse 11 john answered
anyone who has two shirts should share
with the one who has none anyone who has
food I should do the same
verse 12 even tax collectors came to be
baptized so these
for like bad people teacher they asked
what should we do
where's 13 don't collect any more than
you're required to he told that like
that's it just one sentence verse 14
then then some soldiers presumably Roman
soldiers asked him and what about us
what what should we do and you replied
don't extort money don't accuse people
falsely be content with your pay
so you can see what's happening here so
in other words a tax collector comes to
him and I mean honestly if I were John I
would have been like well you've got to
quit your job man like you're in a bad
profession it's evil
so stop but he doesn't say that he
doesn't say you're working for Rome you
know that's another typical profession
quit immediately what do you say he says
wait how do you start here
stop cheating people into the soldier
it's similar
he doesn't shame him he doesn't say well
you're part of the freakin Roman
military industrial complex man you guys
have been conquering the whole world
yeah quit you didn't say that
he's a stop abusing power and then to
the folks who weren't working for the
Roman Empire to the people working the
we'll just call him like you know the
quote-unquote normal jobs the butcher
the baker the candlestick maker he says
well y'all do you see someone without
clothing do you have extra shirt great
give it to them do you see someone
without food give some to them how about
you start there you see I think John was
very perceptive I think he understood
that the problems facing us can be so
big so complex that we are so quickly
overwhelmed into inactivity like we are
overwhelmed into nothingness
we we quit before we've even started
it's like we just see the problems are
like well I can't do anything about that
so just gonna go back to my little life
I was listening to an interview of Andy
stump um who is a former Navy SEAL and
I'm I I don't know why I keep finding
interviews with Navy SEALs and listening
to them so this is like kind of a thing
I'm fascinated by there the pain they
suffer in order to do their job I don't
totally get it but I think it's really
cool
so I was listen to this this guy and
he's not like retired and such but he
was talking about hell week so if you
know anything about this SEALs it's like
a six-month process to become a seal but
they try to leave people out early so
the first sightings around six weeks are
just terrible but till week is a
particularly brutal thing so basically
hell we get sits five days in five
nights of total physical misery you're
lifting logs you're running miles you're
rolling in sand you're sitting in cold
water until you're nearly hypothermic
just day after day after day
and you get four hours of sleep the
entire week not per day four hours
spread out over five days they literally
have doctors on site to monitor the
soldiers because they don't want
something to die
basically it's well tell we so to the
SEAL who he made it through he later
became an instructor and he led other
recruits to know through buzz and
because of this he got to interview
people who quit during hell week because
of course when he was going through it I
mean he's just focused on himself he's
not interviewing people but later yeah
this chance to like talk to them and so
he get to sit with him and ask like why
I mean you said like this was your
lifelong dream because he had their
report in front of them like you you
turned down a Division one college
scholarship to be here and then you got
halfway through the week and did you
you quit like why and he said time and
time again their answer was the same he
said this is what they say I
I just got over well
got overwhelmed like I knew I can't I
can't keep doing this day after day
forever like I keep I just can't do this
and Andy stumpy said they let their
worlds get too big that that line that
has stuck with me for weeks now I keep
thinking about it like they let their
worlds get too big what seat what's he
saying he's saying they started thinking
about the misery of tomorrow and it
overwhelmed them he said and this what
he said thinking for himself because he
was reflecting later like how did I make
it through he said this how I made it
through because my only goal was simply
to make it to the next meal that's how
he made it through he said I knew by law
three times a day no matter what we were
doing they had to feed me and so I told
myself just make your next meal that's
all you got to do Andy that's your world
right here I get to lunch right and so
he said I kept my world small it reminds
me of that old saying how do you eat an
elephant y'all probably heard this one
byte at a time right this is exactly but
what stump is saying keep your world
small and so when the crowds look at
John and they say what what do we even
do like we're a mess but where do we
even begin John says you start here you
start small this is if you can't tell a
1-point sermon tonight that this is my
point you start here start small and
what I think is helpful about this
perspective is that it it works for us
at both of the individual level like me
personally in my own life and as a
society or
societal issues so speak so for example
at the individual level some of you
right now you are overwhelmed by your
life your your there are aspects not
maybe the whole thing but there are key
aspects of your own life and home and
you know your world that are not in
order right so what's the word start
here start small are your finances a
total train wreck will start working on
a budget you say wow you don't
understand man I got shoot I got huge
issues financially it will take me years
to work my way out of this
keep your world small you're you're
letting it get too big and it's
overwhelming you in tune in activity
into well it's so big
I'm just gonna keep medicating myself
money my gals that working working for
you all right how do you eat an elephant
one bite at a time make a budget develop
some disciplines just small little steps
and five years later you look back up I
did it or perhaps you have um like
interpersonal issues like bitterness
resentments with you know relationships
and these things I mean they've been
holding you back for years dragging you
down your relationships will just say
they are not well many of them key once
past hurts are eating you up inside but
but there's they feel so big that you're
just like I just I can't I can't even
and what happened here you're letting
your world get too big working through
all of them sounds completely
overwhelming and so for years you've
done nothing
choose one make amends on your part
forgive the other person have the
conversation or heck if you can have a
conversation write the text or the email
that prepares you to have the
conversation or you're like I can't even
do that okay put a calendar reminder
like into your phone to remind you to
send the text right like just start
start here start small move forward now
like I said the same principle though it
scales up I think to the level of
society and this is what's probably for
many of us very much been on our radar I
mean do we have major societal issues I
say the last three months have revealed
that about is it overwhelming huh anyone
else found themselves up at 2:00 a.m.
think and think and think it right are
you or are you and I I mean are we all
kind of tempted to quit before we've
even begun
uh-huh keep your world small you see
overwhelm is a sign that your world is
getting too big anxiety is a sign your
world it's getting too big you gotta
take radical responsibility for a
problem you see and then just own that
one part as our panelist and thinking
about our panel um two weeks ago um you
know if your burden for example by
something like racial and equality and
it's something perhaps you don't maybe
as a white person you don't really
understand like good okay name that take
responsibility for it right and then ask
a friend you trust for like a book
recommendation and then you're like oh
my gosh a whole book read one page at a
time if it's one page a day like that's
better than nothing right go to one
protest at a time volunteer one hour
maybe it's a week or a month at an
organization you believe in like donate
to a non-profit working for change that
this is how are your life and our world
are changed it's as we respond and
obedience to what God is saying but but
it's not gonna be the big thing it's not
gonna be like in you know poverty in the
whole world like no or even the person
who does that where do they start
well they start
right here they start small it's the one
email it's the phone call it's the next
step it's it's just these little steps
that you look back after a year or five
years or ten years and are like oh my
gosh what has God done this is
incredible I want to close with a quote
from the novel The Brothers Karamazov
one of my favorite novels many of you
know this and it's the the character is
father Zosima and he's a wise and very
holy monk now his audience in the book
he's writing to like other Christian
monks so what I've done instead of a
monk I'm gonna I'm just changed the word
to Christian so that it speaks more to
us us who specifically before the
pandemic we took time each week
presumably to close ourselves within
four walls of a church and contemplate
Christ and in how we could do better
what he was up to in our own hearts and
lives and world like we would do that
right taking that time so I think this
quote will speak speak to you in that in
that context also forgive the very
sexist language it was written in 1879
so it's a product of its time so this is
what father the character father's us in
the rites love one another love God's
people because we have come here and
shut ourselves within these walls we are
no holier than those that are outside
but on the contrary from the very fact
of coming here each of us has confessed
to himself that he is worse than others
at all people on earth and the longer
the Christian lives in his seclusion the
more keenly he must recognize that else
he would have had no reason to come here
when he realizes he's not only worse
than others that he is responsible to
all men for all and everything for all
human sins now
shanell and individual only then the aim
of our seclusion is attained for no dear
ones every one of us is undoubtedly
responsible for all men everything on
earth not merely through the general
sinfulness of creation but each one
personally for all mankind in every
individual this knowledge is the crown
of life for the Christian and for every
person start here start small amen
I'll have a great week
[Music]
I could just sit away from all your
goodness hope to feel your breath I
could just stay I could just stay right
where I am and hope for you hope to feel
something I could hold on I could hold
on to who I and never let you change me
from the inside I could be safe I could
be safe here in your arms and never
never let these walls down but you have
called me higher you will call me deeper
I'll go where you lead me Lord you have
called me higher you have called me deep
[Music]
I could hold on I could hold onto Who I
am it never led changing me from the
inside could be safe oh I could be safe
here in your arms and never leave never
let these walls down but you have called
me higher you have called me deeper and
I'll go where you will lead me you have
called me higher you have called me
deeper and I'll go where you will lead
me where you lead you leave me be yours
from my life
[Music]
thank you Gary and Noel that was
beautiful
and I just wanted to thank everyone for
joining us tonight
just one quick other reminder that one
of the organization's that's doing some
incredible justice work in our area is
the Dallas truth racial and healing and
transformation organization our mission
is to create a radically inclusive city
by addressing race and racism through
narrative change relationship building
and echo policies and practices and you
can ways to find out and join in about
their but their work is at the website
Dallas T rht org
and then I also want to make sure I
close and send you guys a house with
this in addiction in regards to
appreciate Brett's award snipe out I'm
starting off small one of the ways that
I focus on sorry girls follows it and
just in my own personal relationship or
beyond he keeps me some dirt in all of
the craziness and everything like that
is that I know I have peace when I'm
good there and so I just want to close
with this from Ephesians three may
Christ dwell in your hearts through
faith that you may be rooted and
grounded in love may have the strength
to comprehend all the city with all the
saints what is the breadth and length in
the height and depth and to know the
love crisis of passage all knowledge
that you may be filled with all the
fullness of God thank you so much for
joining us tonight not be blessed and
have a good week we'll see you next
Sunday
you